Determine whether the
statement is always,
sometimes, or never true,
and explain why.
So the statement is, 3x is
greater than or equal to x for
all real numbers x.
Well let's try it out with
a couple of numbers.
If you try it out with-- let's
say x is equal to 0.
If x is equal to 0, then
3x is equal to 0.
Which is equal to 0, which
is equal to x.
So in this situation, if x is
equal to 0, 3x is indeed
greater than or equal to x.
In this case, it is equal.
So we know that it's definitely
not never true.
And we could try other
situations.
If you put a 1 here, 3 times 1
is 3, which is greater than or
equal to 1.
So it is either always
or sometimes true.
To cross out always, we just
have to think of a
counterexample.
And a good counterexample would
be a negative number.
If x is negative 1, if x
is equal to negative
1, then what happens?
Then 3x is equal to negative 3
and x-- well, we already said
x is equal to negative 1.
And in that situation, negative
3 is not greater than
or equal to negative 1.
And negative 3 is not greater
than or equal to negative 1.
It's less than negative 1.
So this is a counterexample.
This is not true.
In general, it's not going
to be true for
all negative numbers.
So it's definitely not always.
It's only sometimes true.
It's only true in the case
when you're dealing with
non-negative numbers.
So it's only sometimes true.